well it's that million dollar question
again isn't it the treacherous puzzler
that's frazzling even the world's
biggest brains
what is it is it what's dark matter no
not that one how big is the universe
nope
when did life start
not even that one it's this what is a
woman
good question that is a challenge and a
half oh no
oh this is a problem question in order
to be a woman i feel like you need to
have a wound minute to actually give
birth i guess it depends how you
identify it can mean
whatever you want i know for some people
it means sensitivity or softness but for
some people it means
having really good fashion so it can
mean anything somebody who is
biologically born with two x chromosomes
that's a woman
oh very different
i'm not sure that's even answerable i
don't understand the question i've grown
up believing that is someone who's born
with a vagina and the ability to give
birth and everything but apparently in
this day and age things have changed so
i don't really know anymore to be fair
with you a woman is completely different
to a man who has a
and
things inside that make babies which men
will never have cannot impossible
biologically
impossible nonsense i should think
genitalia for a start it's however you
want to present yourself like femininity
wise or
masculinity-wise there's no set way of
being a woman being a man or whatever
you can flow on either side because it
has nothing to do with
genitals or like your actual body and
stuff like that it's just a
mindset i would say a woman is you know
you are a man and you are a man
that is what i believe
and we believe
what is a woman
ah
i am that's all i know for sure a woman
is
someone
who identifies in a feminine way whether
that's their
outward appearance or
their inner self someone who has
identified someone a woman is the
opposite of a man
i guess
outside of the spectrum
a woman is
opposite to a man she has a reproductive
system she can give life she can give
birth to babies
and that's it yeah in order to give
birth you have to be a woman to be
classed as a woman in my view you should
be born with a womb you can be female
you can be feminine but you can't be a
woman i think it is a really difficult
question now
my initial inclination would always be
someone who was physiologically
born with female attributes i would want
to make a distinction though between
sex sexuality and gender i do believe
that men
can become women
through
transsexuality
although i am extremely dubious about
the whole issue of people just saying
i am a man when they're genetically a
woman or i am a woman when they're
genetically a man just think
you be you and if you want to be
a man or a woman
then that's that's your choice you know
you do you a woman is
everyone who feels as such
and it's as simple as that